LAURENCE MORONEY: All right.
Shall we get started?
So thanks, everybody, for
coming to this session.
I'm going to be talking
about TensorFlow
and particularly TensorFlow from
a programmer's perspective--
so machine learning
for programmers.
I'd like to show some code
samples of using TensorFlow
in some simple scenarios as
well as one slightly more
advanced scenario.
But before I do that, I
always like to just do
a little bit of a level set.
And if you were at the
previous session, sorry,
some of the content's
going to be similar to what
you've seen already.
But when I like
to think about AI,
and when I come to conferences
like this one about AI,
or if I read the news
about AI, there's
always stories about what it
can do or what it might do,
but there's not a whole lot
about what it actually is.
So part of my mandate and
part of what I actually
like to educate people
around is from a programmer's
perspective, what AI actually
is, what it is for you,
what you can begin to
learn how to program,
and then how you can apply it
to your business scenarios.
But we're also at the
cusp of this revolution
in this technology,
and lots of people
are calling it like the
fourth Industrial Revolution.
And for me, I can
only describe it
as like it's the third big
shift in my own personal career.
And so for me, the first one
came in the early to mid-90s
when the web came about.
And if you remember
when the web came about,
we were all desktop programmers.
I personally-- my
first job was I
was a Visual Basic
programmer programming
Windows applications.
Anybody ever do that?
It was fun, wasn't it?
And so then the web came around,
and what happened with the web
then is it changed the
audience of your application
from one person at a time
to many people at a time.
You had to start
thinking differently
about how you built
your applications to be
able to scale it to
lots of people using it.
And also, the runtime changed.
Instead of you being able
to write something that
had complete control
over the machine,
you would write something to
this sort of virtual machine
that the browser gave you.
And then maybe that browser
would have plugins like Java
and stuff like
that you could use
to make it more intelligent.
But as a result, what
ended up happening
was this paradigm shift gave
birth to whole new industries.
And I work for a small
company called Google.
Anybody heard of them?
And so things like
Google weren't possible.
Anybody remember gophers?
Yeah, so that's really
old school, right?
What gophers where were almost
the opposite of a search
engine.
A search engine, like--
you type something into
it, and it has already
found the results, and
it gives them to you.
A gopher was this
little application
that you would send out
into the nascent internet,
and it would crawl everywhere,
a little bit like a spider,
and then come back
with results for you.
So for me, whoever
had the great idea
to say, let's flip
the axes on that
and come up with this
new business paradigm,
ended up building the
first search engines.
And as a result, companies like
Google and Yahoo were born.
Ditto with things
like Facebook--
that wouldn't have been
possible with the browser.
Can you imagine trying to--
pre-internet, where there
was no standard protocol
for communication, and you'd
write desktop applications--
can imagine being able
to build something
like a Facebook or a Twitter?
It just wasn't possible.
So that became--
to me, the web was
this first great tectonic shift
in my own personal career.
The second one then came with
the advent of the smartphone.
So now users had
this device that they
can put in their
pocket that's got
lots of computational power.
It's got memory.
It's got storage,
and it's loaded
with sensors like cameras,
and GPS, et cetera.
Now think about the
types of applications
that you could build with that.
Now it's a case of companies
like Uber became possible.
Now, I personally
believe, by the way
that all of the
applications are built
by introverts because you'll
see all of these great things
that you can do nowadays is
because they serve introverts.
I'm highly introverted,
and one thing I hate to do
is stand on a street
corner and hail a taxi.
So when Uber came along, it was
like a dream come true for me
that I could just do
something on my phone,
and a car would show up.
And now it's shopping.
It's the same kind
of thing, right?
I personally really
dislike going to a store
and having somebody
say, can I help you?
Can I do something for you?
Can I help you find something?
I'm introverted.
I want to go find it myself,
put my eyes down, and take it
to the cash register,
and pay for it.
And now online shopping,
it's done the same thing.
So I don't know why I went
down that rabbit hole,
but it's just one that I find
that the second tectonic shift
has been the advent of
the mobile application
so that these new businesses,
these new companies
became possible.
So the third one
that I'm seeing now
is the AI and the machine
learning revolution.
Now, there's so much
hype around this,
so I like to draw a
diagram of the hype cycle.
And so if you think
about the hype cycle,
every hype cycle starts
off with some kind
of technological trigger.
Now, with AI and
machine learning,
that technological
trigger really
happened a long time ago.
Machine learning
has been something,
and AI has been something
that's been in universities.
It's been in industry
for quite some time--
decades.
So it's only relatively
recently that the intersection
of compute power and data
has made it possible so
that now everybody can jump
on board-- not just university
researchers.
And with the power of
things such as TensorFlow
that I'm going to show
later, anybody with a laptop
can start building
neural networks
where in the past
were reserved for the
very best of universities.
So that technological
trigger that's rebooted,
in many ways, the
AI infrastructure,
has only happened in
the last few years.
And with any hype
cycle, what happens
is you end up with this peak
of increased expectations
where everybody is thinking
AI's going to be the be-all
and end-all, and will
change the world,
and will change
everything as we know it,
before it falls into the
trough of disillusionment.
And then at some point,
we get enlightenment,
and then we head up
into the productivity.
So when you think
about the web, when
you think about mobile
phones and those revolutions
that I spoke about, they
all went through this cycle,
and AI went through this cycle.
Now, you can ask 100 people
where we are on this life cycle
right now, and you'd probably
get 100 different answers.
But I'm going to
give my answer that I
think we're right about here.
And when we start looking
at the news cycle,
it kind of shows that.
We start looking at news.
We start looking at
glossy marketing videos.
AI's is going to do this.
AI's was going to do that.
At the end of the day, AI
isn't really doing any of that.
It's smart people
building neural networks
with a new form of, a new
metaphor for programming
have been the ones who've
been able to do them,
have been able to build
out these new scenarios.
So we're still
heading up that curve
of increased expectations.
And at some point,
we're probably
going to end up in the
trough of disillusionment
before things will get real and
you'll be able to really build
whatever the Uber or the
Google of the AI generation's
going to be.
It may be somebody in
this room will do that.
I don't know.
So at Google, we have
this graph that we
draw that we train
our internal engineers
and our internal folks around AI
and around the hype around AI.
And we like to layer
it in these three ways.
First of all, AI,
from a high level,
is the ability to
program a computer
to act like an
intelligent human.
And how do you do that?
There might be some
traditional coding in that,
but there may also be
something called machine
learning in that.
And what machine learning is
all about is instead of writing
code where it's all about how
the human solves a problem,
how they think about a
problem, and expressing that
in a language like
Java, C#, or C++,
it's a case of you train
a computer by getting it
to recognize patterns and then
open up whole new scenarios
in that way.
I'm going to talk about
that in a little bit more.
And then another
part of that is deep
learning with the idea
behind deep learning
is now machines being able
to take over some of the role
that humans are taking in
the machine learning phase.
And where machine
learning is all about--
I'm going to, for
example, show a slide next
about activity detection.
But in the case of
activity detection,
instead of me explicitly
programming a computer
to detect activities,
I will train a computer
based on people doing
those activities.
So let me think about it.
Let me describe it this way.
First of all, how many people
in this room are coders?
Have written code?
Oh, wow, most of you.
OK, cool.
What languages, out of interest?
Just shout them out.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LAURENCE MORONEY: C#.
Thank you.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Python.
OK.
I've written about a
bunch of books on C#.
I still love it.
I don't get to use it anymore,
but it's nice to hear.
So I heard C#.
I heard Python.
C++?
OK, cool.
Now, what do all of these
languages have in common?
Ruby?
Nice.
What do all of these
languages have in common?
That you, as a developer,
have to figure out
how to express a problem
in that language, right?
So if you think about if you're
building a problem, if you're
building an application
for activity detection,
and say you want to detect an
activity of somebody walking--
like I'm wearing a
smartwatch right now.
I love it because since I
started wearing smartwatches,
I became much more
conscious of my own fitness.
And I think about how this
smartwatch monitors my activity
that when I start
running, I want
it to know that I'm running,
so it logs that I'm running.
When I start walking,
I want it to do
the same thing,
and count calories,
and all that kind of stuff.
But if you think about it from
a coding perspective, how would
you build a smartwatch like
this one if you're a coder?
Now, you might, for example,
be able to detect the speed
that the person's moving
at, and you'd write
a little bit of code like this.
If speed is less than 4,
then the person's walking.
That's kind of naive because
if you're walking uphill,
you're probably going slower.
If you're walking downhill,
you're going faster.
But I'll just keep
it simple like that.
So in code, you have
a problem, and you
have to express the
problem in a way
that the computer understands
that you can compile,
and then you build an
application out of it.
So now I say, OK,
what if I'm running?
If I'm running, well, I can
probably go by the speed again.
And I say, hey, if my speed
is less than a certain amount,
I'm walking.
Otherwise, I'm running.
I go, OK.
Now I've built an
activity detector,
and it detects if I'm
walking or if I'm running.
Pretty cool.
Pretty easy to do with code.
So I go, OK.
Now, my next scenario is biking.
And I go, OK.
If I'm going based on the
speed, the data of my speed,
I can do a similar thing.
If I say if my speed is less
than this much, I'm walking.
Otherwise, I'm running,
or otherwise I'm biking.
So great.
I've now written an
activity detector--
a very naive activity detector--
just by looking at the speed
that the person's moving at.
But now my boss
loves to play golf,
and he's like, this is great.
I want you to detect golf, and
tell me when I'm playing golf,
and calculate what I'm
doing when I'm playing golf.
How do I do that?
I'm in what I call,
as a programmer,
the oh crap phase because now
I realize that all of this code
that I've written, and all
this code that I'm maintaining,
I now have to throw
away because it can't
be used in something like this.
This scenario just doesn't
become possible with the code
that I've written.
So when I think about going
back to the revolutions
that I spoke about--
for example,
something like an Uber
wouldn't have been possible
before the mobile phone.
Something like a Google
wouldn't have been possible
before the web.
And something like
my golf detector,
it wouldn't be
possible or would be
extremely difficult
without machine learning.
So what is machine learning?
So traditional
programming I like
to summarize in a
diagram like this one.
And traditional programming is a
case of you express rules using
a programming language like
Ruby, or C#, or whatever.
And you have data
that you feed into it,
and you compile
that into something
that gives you answers.
So keeping the
very simple example
that I have of an
activity detector, that's
giving me the answer
of you're playing golf.
You're running.
You're walking-- all
those kind of things.
The machine learning revolution
just flips the axes on this.
So the idea behind the
machine learning revolution
is now I feed in answers, I feed
in data, and I get out rules.
So instead of me needing
to have the intelligence
to define the rules
for something,
this revolution is
saying that, OK, I'm
going to tell a computer
that I'm doing this,
I'm doing that, I'm
doing the other,
and it's going to
figure out the rules.
It's going to match
those patterns
and figure out the rules for me.
So now something like my
activity detector for golf,
and walking, and
running changes.
So now instead of me writing the
code for that, I would say, OK.
I'm going to get lots
of people to walk.
I'm going to get lots of
people to wear whatever
sensor it is-- like maybe
it's a watch or a smartphone--
in their pocket.
And I'm going to
gather all that data,
and I'm going to
tell a computer,
this is what walking looks like.
I'm going to do the
same for running.
same for biking.
And I may as well do
the same for golfing.
So now my scenario
becomes expandable,
and I can start detecting things
that I previously would not
have been able to detect.
So I've opened up new scenarios
that I previously would not be
able to program by using
if-then rules or using whatever
language--
C.
Anybody remember
the language Prolog?
Anybody use that?
Yeah.
Even Prolog couldn't
handle that,
even though they said
Prolog was an AI language.
So the idea behind this
is it kind of emulates
how the human mind works.
So instead of me
telling the computer
by having the intelligence to
know what golf looks like, I
train the computer by
taking data about what
golf looks like, and the
computer recognizes that data,
matches that data.
So in the future, when
I give it more data,
it will say, that kind
of looks like golf,
so I'm going to
say this is golf.
So we talk about learning.
We talk about the human brain.
So I always like to
think like, well,
think about how you
learn something--
like maybe this game.
Anybody remember this game?
Everybody knows how to
play this game, right?
It seems, by the
way, this game has
different names
in every country,
and it's always
hard to remember.
I grew up calling it
knots and crosses.
Ed's nodding.
Most people grew
up maybe calling
in this country tic-tac-toe.
I gave a talk similar to this
in Japan earlier this year,
and they had this really
strange name that I
couldn't remember for it.
But this is a very
simple game, right?
Now, if I were to ask you
to play that game right now,
and it's your move,
where would you go?
How many people would
go in the center?
not go in the center?
We need to talk.
So you've probably learned
this as a young child--
and maybe you teach
this to children.
But the strategy of
winning this game.
If it's your turn, you
will never win this game,
unless you're playing
against somebody
who doesn't know how
to play the game,
by not going in
the center first.
Now, remember how
you learned that.
OK?
If you have a really
tough teacher like me,
I would teach my
kids by beating them
every time at the game
and that kind of stuff.
So if they would start in the
corner, I would beat them.
And they would start
somewhere else,
and I would beat
them-- at the game.
And keep doing
this kind of thing
until they eventually
figured out
that they have to
go in the center,
or they're going to lose.
So that was a case of this is
how the human brain learns.
So how do we teach a
computer the same way?
Now think about, for
example, if your kids goes,
and they've never seen
this board before.
So in this society, we read
left to right, top to bottom.
So the first thing
they'd probably do
is go in the top
left-hand corner.
And then you'd go in the
center, and then they'd
go somewhere else.
And you go somewhere else, and
then they go somewhere else,
and you get three in a
row, and you beat them.
They now have what, in
machine language parlance,
is a labeled example.
They see the board.
They remember what
they did on the board,
and that's been
labeled as they lost.
Then they might
play again, and they
have another labeled
example of they lost.
And they'll keep doing that
until they have labeled
examples of tying and
then maybe, eventually,
labeled examples of winning.
So knowing how to
learn is a step
towards this kind
of intelligence.
And this is when we talk
about machine learning,
we get our data,
and we label them.
It's exactly the
same as teaching
a child how to play tic-tac-toe
or knots and crosses.
So let's take a look at--
so if I go back to this
diagram for a moment
before I look at some
code, now the idea
is thinking in terms
of tic-tac-toe,
you have the answers of
experience of playing the game.
You have the labels for that--
that you won, you
lost, whatever.
And out of that, as a human,
you'd begin to infer the rules.
Did anybody ever teach
you you must go first?
Must go in the center first.
If you don't go in the center
first, you go in a corner.
If you don't go in a
corner, you block somebody
with two in a row?
You don't learn by
those if-then rules.
I know I didn't, and most
people I speak to didn't.
So as a result, they
ended up playing the game,
and they infer the
rules for themselves,
and it's exactly the same
thing with machine learning.
So you build something.
The computer learns
how to infer the rules
with a neural network.
And then at runtime,
you give it data,
and it will give you
back classifications,
or predictions, or give you
back intelligent answers based
on the data that you've given it
So let's look at some code.
So this is what we call
the training phase.
This is what we call
the inference phase.
But enough theory.
So I like to explain a
lot of this in coding.
So a very simple
Hello, World scenario,
as all programmers have, is I'm
going to get use some numbers.
And I'm going to give
you some numbers,
and there's a relationship
between these numbers.
And let's see who can figure
out what the relationship is.
Are you ready?
OK.
Here's the numbers .
So where x is minus
1, y is minus 3.
Where x is 0, y is minus
1, et cetera, et cetera.
Can you see the relationship
between the x and the y?
So if y equals something,
what would y equal?
AUDIENCE: 2x minus 1.
LAURENCE MORONEY: 2x minus 1.
Excellent.
So the relationship here
is y equals 2x minus 1.
How do you know that?
How did you get that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: What's that?
LAURENCE MORONEY: I
can't hear you, sorry.
AUDIENCE: It's
called a linear fit.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Oh, linear fit.
OK, thanks.
Yeah.
So you've probably done some
basic geometry in school,
and you think about usually
there's a relationship.
Y equals mx plus c,
something along those lines.
So you start plugging
in m and the c in.
And then your mind
ultimately finds
something that works, right?
So you go, OK.
Well, if y is minus
3, maybe that's
a couple of x's, which
will give me minus 2.
And I'll subtract 1 from
that, give me minus 3.
And then I'll try
that with 0 and 1.
Yep, that works.
Now I'll try that with 1 and 1.
That works.
So what happened is there
were a couple of parameters
around the y that
you started guessing
what those parameters were and
started trying to fit them in
to get that relationship.
That's exactly what a
neural network does,
and that's exactly the process
of training a neural network.
When you train a neural
network to try and pick
a relationship between numbers
like this, all it's doing
is guessing those random
parameters, calculating--
look through each
of the parameters,
calculate which ones it got
right, which ones it got wrong,
calculate how far it
got them wrong by,
and then try and come up with
new values that would be closer
to getting more of them right.
And that's the process
called training.
So whenever you see
training and talking
about needing lots of cycles for
training, needing lots of GPU
time for training, all the
computer is doing is trying,
failing, trying, failing,
trying, failing, but each time
getting a little
closer to the answer.
So let's look at
the code for that.
So using TensorFlow
and using Keras--
I don't have the
code on my laptop,
so I've got to look
back at the screen.
Sorry.
So using TensorFlow
and Keras, here's
how I'm going to
define a neural network
to do that linear fitting
in just a few lines.
So the first thing
I'm going to do
is I'm going to create
my neural network.
This is the simplest
possible neural network.
It's got one layer
with one neuron in it.
And this is the code to do that.
So where you see
keras.layers.Dense(units=1,
input shape=1), that's all
that I'm doing is I'm saying
I've got a single neuron.
I'm going to pass a
single number into that,
and you're going to try and
figure out what the number I
want to come out of that is.
So very, very simple.
So then my next line
of code is remember
I said all a neural
network is going to do
is try and guess
the parameters that
will make all the numbers fit?
So it will come up with
a couple of rough guesses
for these parameters.
And then it has
these two functions.
One's called a loss function,
and one's called an optimizer.
And all they're doing is--
if you remember that set
of six numbers I gave you,
it's saying, OK.
Well if y equals something
times x plus something,
I'm going to guess
those two somethings.
I'm going to measure how
many of my y's I got right.
I'm going to measure how far
I'm wrong in all of the ones
that I got wrong,
and then I'm going
to try and guess new values
for those somethings.
So the loss function
is the part where
it's measuring how
far it got wrong,
and the optimizer is saying, OK.
Here's what I got the last time.
I'm going to try to guess
these new parameters,
and I'll keep going until
I get y equals 2x minus 1
or something along those lines.
So that's all you do.
You just compile your model.
You specify the loss function.
You specify the optimizer.
These are both really
heavy mathy things.
One of the nice
things about Keras,
one of the nice things
about TensorFlow,
is they're all done for you.
You're just going to
specify them in code.
And so I'm going
to say, I'm going
to try the mean squared
error as my loss function.
And I'm going to
try something called
SGD, which is
stochastic gradient
descent as my optimizer.
And every time it
loops around, it's
going to just guess new
parameters based on those.
OK.
So then the next
thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to feed my
values into my neural network.
So I'm going to
say, my x is going
to be this array-- minus
1, 0, 1, et cetera.
My y is that going
to be this array.
So here I'm creating the data.
And so I just get
them, and I load them
into a couple of arrays.
This is Python code, by the way.
And now all that I'm going to
ask my neural network to do
is to try and come
up with an answer.
And I do that with
the fit method.
So here I just say, hey, try
and fit my x's to my y's.
And this epochs=500 means you're
going to just try 500 times.
So it's going to loop
500 times like that.
Remember I was saying it's
going to get those parameters.
It's going to get it wrong.
It's going to optimize.
It's going to guess again.
It's going to get it wrong.
It's going to optimize.
So in this case in my code, I'm
just saying do that 500 times.
And at the end of
those 500 times,
it's going to come
up with a model
that if I gave it a y-- sorry.
If I give it an x, it's
going to give me what
it thinks the y is for that x.
OK.
And you do that using
model.predict().
So if I pass it model.predict()
for the value 10,
what do you think
it would give me?
If you remember the numbers
from earlier, y is 2x minus 1.
What do you think it would give?
19, right?
It doesn't because it will
give me something really close
to 19.
It gives me about
18.97, and I'm going
to try to run the code
in a moment to show.
But why do you think
it would do that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: What's that?
AUDIENCE: It's predicting.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
It's predicting.
And it's just been trained
on a very few pieces of data.
With those six pieces of
data, it looks like a line,
and it looks like a
linear relationship,
but it might not be.
There's room for error there
that with the fact that I'm
training on very,
very little data,
this could be a small part of
a line that, for all we know,
goes like this instead of
being linear once you move out
of those points.
And as a result,
those kind of things
get factored into the model
as the model's training on it.
So you'll see it's going
to get a very close answer,
but it's not going to
be an exact answer.
Let me see if I can
get the code running.
It's a little complex
with this laptop.
When I'm presenting, it's
hard to move stuff over
to that screen.
Just one second.
This requires some mouse-fu.
All right.
So I have that code.
Let's see.
Yeah.
So you can see that code I
have now running up there.
And if you look right at the
bottom of the screen over here,
we can see here's where it has
actually done the training.
It's done 500 epochs
worth of training.
And then when I called
the model.predict(),
it gave me this answer,
which is 18.976414.
And so that was one
that I ran earlier.
I'm just going to try and
run it again now, if I can.
But it's really hard to see.
So I'll click that Run arrow.
So this IDE is
PyCharm, by the way.
So you see that it ran
very quickly because it's
a very simple neural network.
And as a result, I
was able to train it
through 500 epochs in whatever
that is-- half a second.
What did it give me this time?
Was it 18.9747?
Is that what I see?
So again, very simple neural
network, very simple code,
but this just shows some of
the basics for how it works.
So next, I want to just get to
a slightly more advanced example
once I get my slides back.
Whoops.
OK.
So that was very simple.
That was Hello, World.
We all remember our first Hello,
World program which we wrote.
If you wrote it in Java,
it was like 10 lines.
If you wrote it in
C#, it was five lines.
Python, it was one line.
If you wrote it in C++,
it was like 300 lines.
[LAUGHTER]
Do you remember that--
I remember Petzold's book
on programming Windows.
Anybody ever read that?
The whole first chapter was
how to do Hello, World in MFC,
and it was like 15 pages long.
I thought it was great.
But that was a
pretty easy example.
That, to me, is the Hello,
World of machine learning-- just
doing that basic linear fitting.
But let's think about
something more complicated.
So here are some
items of clothing.
Now, as a human, you are looking
at these items of clothing,
and you've instantly
classified them.
And you instantly
recognize them, or at least
hopefully most of them.
But think about the
difficulty for a computer
to classify them.
For example, there are
two shoes on this slide.
One is the high heel
shoe in the upper right,
and one is the sneaker
in the second row.
But they look really
different to each other--
other than the fact
that they're both red,
and you think they
vaguely fit a foot.
The high heel, obviously your
foot has to change to fit it.
And the sneaker,
the foot is flat.
But as a human brain, we
automatically recognize these,
and we see these as shoes.
Or if we look at the two shirts
in the image, one of them
doesn't have arms
because we automatically
see it as being folded--
the one with the tie.
And then the green one
in the lower left--
we already know it's a
shirt-- it's a t-shirt--
because we recognize it as such.
But think about how would
you program a computer
to recognize these things,
given the differences?
It's really hard to
tell the difference
between a high heeled shoe
and a sneaker, for example.
So the idea behind this
is there's actually a data
set called Fashion MNIST.
And what it does is it gets
70,000 items of clothing,
and it's labeled those
70,000 items of clothing
in 10 different classes from
shirts, to shoes, to handbags,
and all that kind of thing.
And it's built into Keras.
So one of the really neat things
that came out of the research
behind this, by the way, is
that the images are only 28
by 28 pixels.
So if you think about, it's
faster to train a computer
if you're using less data.
You saw how quickly I trained
with my linear example
earlier on.
But if I were to
try and train it
with high definition
images of handbags
and that kind of stuff,
it would still work,
but it would just be slower.
And a lot of the research
that's gone into this dataset,
they've actually been
able to train and show
how to train a neural
network that all you need
is a 28 by 28
pixel image for you
to be able to tell
the difference
between different
items of clothing.
As you are doing probably
right now, you can take a look,
and you see which
ones are pants,
which ones are
shoes, which ones are
handbags, that kind of thing.
So this allows us to
build a model that's
very, very quick to train.
And if I take a look,
here's an example
of one item of clothing
in 28 by 28 pixels.
And you automatically
recognize that, right?
It's a boot, or a shoe, or
something along those lines.
And so this is the kind
of resolution of data--
all you need to be able to
build an accurate classifier.
So let's look at
the code for that.
So if you remember earlier on,
the code that I was building
was I created the
neural network.
I compiled a neural
network by specifying
the loss function and the
optimizer, and then I fit it.
So in this case, a
little bit more complex.
Your code's going to look like--
you're going to use TensorFlow.
From TensorFlow, you're going
to import the Keras namespace
because the Keras namespace
really nicely gives you access
to that Fashion MNIST dataset.
So think about all the
code that you'd typically
have to write to download
those 70,000 images,
download their
labels, correspond
a label with an image,
load all of that in--
that kind of stuff.
All that coding is
saved and just put
into these two lines of code.
And that's one of the neat
things also about Python that I
find that makes Python great for
machine learning because that
second line of code there
where it's like train_images,
train_labels, test_images,
test_labels equals
fashion_mnist.load_data(),
what that's actually doing is
it's loading data from the
dataset which is stored
in the cloud.
It's sorting that 70,000
items of data into four sets.
Those four sets are then split
into two sets, one for training
and one for testing.
And that data is going to
contain-- the one on the left
there, the training
images, is 60,000 images
and 60,000 labels.
And then the other side is
10,000 images and 10,000 labels
that you're going
to use for testing.
Now, anybody guess why would
you separate them like this?
Why would you have
a different set
for testing than you
would have for training?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: The
clue's in the name.
So how do you know
your neural network
is going to work unless
you've got something
to test it against?
Earlier, we could test
with our linear thing
by feeding 10 in because I
know I'm expecting 2x minus 1
to give me 19.
But now it's a
case of, well, it'd
be great for me to be able
to test it against something
that's known, against
something that's labeled,
so I can measure the
accuracy as I go forward.
So that's all I
got to do in code.
So now if I come
back here, let's look
at how we actually define
the neural net-- oh, sorry.
Before I do that, so
the training images
are things like the boot
that I showed you earlier on.
It's 28 by 28 pixels.
The labels are
actually just going
to be numbers rather than
like a word like shoe.
Why do you think that would be?
So that you can define
your own labels,
and you're not
limited to English.
So for example, 09 in English
could be an ankle boots.
The second one is in Chinese.
The third one is in Japanese.
And the fourth language,
can anybody guess?
Brog ruitin?
That's actually Irish Gaelic.
Sorry, I'm biased.
I have to put some in.
So now, for example, I
could build a classifier
not just to give me
items of clothing
but to do it in
different languages.
So that's just what my labels
are going to look like.
So now let's take
a look at the code
for defining my neural network.
So here is-- if you remember
the first line of code
where I defined the single
layer with the single neuron
for the classification, this is
what it's going to look like.
And this is all it takes to
build this clothing classifier.
So you see there are
three layers here.
The first layer, where it says
keras.layers.Flatten(input
shape=(28, 28)), all that is
is I'm defining a layer to take
in 28 squared values.
Remember, the image is a
square of 28 by 28 pixels,
but you don't feed a neural
network with a square.
You feed it with a
flat layer of values.
In this case, the values
are between 0 and 256.
So I'm just flattening
that out, and I'm
saying, that's my first layer.
You're going to take in
whatever 28 squared is.
My second layer now
is just 128 neurons,
and there's an activation
function on them
which I'll explain in a moment.
And then my third layer
is going to be 10 neurons.
Why do you think there
are 10 in that one?
Can anybody guess?
So 28 squared for the
inputs, 10 for the output.
Anybody remember where the
number 10 was mentioned?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Yeah, number of labels.
There were 10 different classes.
So what happens when
a neural network,
when you train it like this one,
it's not just going to pop out
and give you an answer and
say, this is number 03,
or this is number 04.
Typically what will
happen is that you
want to have 10 outputs for
your 10 different labels,
and each output is going to
give you a probability that it
is that label.
So for example, the boot that
I showed earlier on was labeled
09, so neuron 0 is going to
give me a very low number.
Neuron 1 is going to give
me a very low number.
Neuron 2 is going to give
Neuron 9 is going to give
me a very high number.
And then by looking at
the outputs across all
of these neurons,
I can now determine
which one the neural network
thinks it's classified for.
Remember, we're training
this with a bunch of data.
So I'm giving it a whole bunch
of data to say this is what
a number 09 looks like.
This is what a
number 04 looks like.
number 03 looks like.
By saying, OK, this
is what they are.
I encode the data
in the same way.
And as a result, we'll
get our output like this.
Now, every neuron has what's
called an activation function.
And the idea behind that-- it's
a very mathy kind of thing.
But in programmer's terms, the
tf.nn.relu that you see there--
if you think about
this in terms of code,
if I say if x is greater
than zero, return x.
Else, return zero.
OK?
Very simple function, and
that's what the relu is.
And all that's going to do is
as the code is being filtered in
and then down into
those neurons,
all of the stuff that's
negative just gets filtered out.
So as a result, it
makes it much quicker
for you to train your
neural network by getting
rid of things that are
negative, they're by rid
of things you don't need.
So every time when you specify
a layer in a neural network,
there's usually an activation
function like that.
Relu is one of the
most common ones
that you'll see, particularly
for classification
things like this.
But again, relu is
a very mathy thing.
A lot of times, you go
to the documentation,
you'll wonder what relu is.
You'll go look it up.
You'll see a page
full of Greek letters.
I don't understand that stuff.
So for me, something
like relu is as simple
as if x is greater
than zero, return x.
Else, return zero.
All right.
So now I've defined
my neural network.
And the next thing
I'm going to do,
you'll see the
same code as we saw
earlier on where
what I'm going to do
is compile my neural network.
And in compiling
my neural network,
I've got to specify
the loss, and I've
got to specify the optimizer.
Now, there's a whole
bunch of different types
of loss functions.
There's a whole bunch
of different types
of optimizer functions.
When you read academic research
papers around AI, a lot of them
specialize on these to say,
for this type of problem,
you should use a loss function
of sparse categorical cross
entropy because x.
For this type of
problem, you should
use an optimizer, which is
an Adam-based optimizer,
because x.
A lot of this as a
programmer, you just
have to learn through
trial and error.
I could specify the same loss
function and the same optimizer
that I use for my linear
and then try and train
my neural network, see
how accurate it is,
how quick it is.
And then I could try these
ones, see how accurate it is,
see how quick it is.
There's a lot of trial
and error in that way.
And understanding which
ones to use right now
is an inexact science.
It's a lot like, for example,
as a traditional coder, which
is better-- using a
for loop or a do loop?
Which is better-- using
a while or using a when?
Those type of things.
And as a result,
you see as you're
building your neural
networks, there's
a lot of trial and error
that you'll do here.
But reading academic
papers can certainly
help if you can understand them.
So in this case now, like
for the Fashion MNIST,
after a bit of
trial and error, we
ended up selecting
for the tutorial
to use these two
functions. / But as you
read through the
documentation, you'll
see all the functions
that are available.
So in this case, I'm training
it with an AdamOptimizer.
And remember, the
process of training,
every iteration it will
make a guess that says, OK.
This piece of data,
I think it's a shoe.
OK, it's not a shoe.
It's a dress.
Why did I get it wrong?
I'll use my loss function to
calculate where I got it wrong,
and then I'll use my
optimizer to change
my weights on the next
loop to try and see
if I can get it better.
This is what the neural
network is thinking.
This how it works as you're
actually training it.
So in this case,
the AdamOptimizer
is what it's using to
do that optimization.
The categorical cross entropy
is what it's using for the loss.
So now if I train it, it's the
same thing that we saw earlier
on-- model.fit().
So all I'm going to say
is, hey, model.fit().
I'm going to train it with
the input images and the input
labels, and in this
case, I'm going
to train it for five epochs.
OK.
So that epochs number,
it's up to you to tweak it.
What you'll do as you're
training your network
and as you're
testing your network,
you'll see how accurate it is.
Sometimes you can get the
process called converging,
means as it gets more
and more accurate,
sometimes you'll
find convergence
in only a few epochs.
Sometimes, you'll need
hundreds of epochs.
Of course, the bigger
and more complex
the dataset, and the more
labels that you have,
the longer it takes to
actually train and converge.
But the Fashion MNIST
dataset, actually
using the neural network that I
defined in the previous slide,
five epochs is actually
pretty accurate.
It gets there pretty
quickly with just five.
OK.
And now if I then just want to
test it and the model itself--
again, the important object
here is the model object.
So if I call model.evaluate(),
and I pass it the test images
and the text labels, it will
then iterate through the 10,000
test images and test labels.
It will calculate.
It will say, I think
it's going to be this.
It will compare
it with the label.
If it gets it right,
it improves its score.
If it gets it wrong,
it decreases its score,
and it gives you
that score back.
So the idea here
is-- remember earlier
when we separated the data into
60,000 for training and 10,000
for test?
Instead of you manually writing
all that code to do all that,
you can just call the evaluate()
function on the model,
pass it the test stuff, and it
will give you back the results.
It will do all that looping
and checking for you.
All right.
And then, of course, if I
want to predict an image,
if I have my own images, and
I've formatted them into 28
by 28 grayscale, and
I put them into a set,
now I can just say
model.predict() my images,
and it will give me back
a set of predictions.
Now, what do those
predictions look like?
So for every image, because the
output of the neural network
was--
there were 10 layers,
so every image
is going to give you
back a set of 10 numbers.
And those 10 numbers, as
I mentioned earlier on,
nine of them should be very
close to 0, and one of them
should be very close to 1.
And then using the one
that's very close to 1,
you could determine
your prediction
to be whatever that
item of clothing is.
So if I demo this
and show it in code--
let's see.
Go back here.
It's really hard to
see it, so forgive me.
Whoops.
I'm going to select Fashion--
oh.
I really need a mouse.
I'm going to select Fashion.
OK.
And can you see
the fashion code,
or is it's still
showing the linear code?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Is
that fashion right there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: All right.
OK.
Did I just close it?
I'm sorry.
It's really hard to see.
So let me go back.
Is that one fashion?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Up one?
All right.
That one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
So here's the code that I was
showing on the earlier slide.
So this is exactly the same
code that was on my slides.
I'm just going to go down.
There's one thing I've done
here that I didn't show
on the slides, and that
was the images themselves
were grayscales, so every
pixel was between 0 and 256.
For training my
neural network, it
was just easier for me
to normalize that data.
So instead of it
being from 0 to 255,
it's a value from 0 to 1, which
is relative to that value.
And that's what those
two lines of codes there.
And that's one of the things
that makes Python really
useful for this kind of thing.
Because I can just say
that train_images set
is a set of 60,000
28 by 28 images,
and I can just say
divide that by 255,
and that normalized that for me.
So that's one of the
things that makes Python
really handy in data science.
So we can see it's
just the same code.
So I'm going to do a bit of
live audience participation.
Hopefully, I can get
it to work with us.
So remember I said there
are 10,000 testing images?
OK.
So somebody give me a
number between 0 and 99,999.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Don't be shy.
LAURENCE MORONEY: What's that?
Just 27?
OK.
So hopefully I can see
it so I can get it.
That's not 27, is it?
OK.
27.
And here-- 27.
I tested it earlier
what value 4560.
So what's going
to happen here is
that I'm going to train the
neural network to identify
those pieces of clothing.
And so-- or to be able to
identify pieces of clothing.
I have no idea what piece
of clothing number 27
is in the test set.
But what it's going to do
once it's done is by the end,
you'll see it says print
the test labels for 27.
So whatever item
of clothing 27 is,
there's is a pre-assigned
label for that.
It will print that out.
And then the next
thing it'll do is
it will print out what the
predicted label will be.
And hopefully, the two of
them are going to be the same.
There's about a 90% chance, if
I remember right from this one,
that they will.
So if I run it, it's going
to take a little longer
than the previous one.
So now we can see it starting
to train the network.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
because I'm doing in PyCharm,
I can see in my debug window.
So you can see the epochs--
epoch 2, epoch 3, epoch 4.
This accuracy number here is how
accurate it is against testing.
So it's about 89% correct.
And then you see it's actually
printed two numbers below,
and they're both 0.
So that means for item
of clothing number 27,
that class was 0.
And then the predicted for
that class was actually also 0,
so it got it right.
Yay.
Anybody want to try one
more just to prove that?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Let's see if we can--
what's that?
AUDIENCE: 42.
LAURENCE MORONEY: 42, I love it.
That's the ultimate answer,
but what is the question?
OK.
42.
And I'm guessing 42 is probably
also item 0, but let's see.
Hopefully, I haven't broken
any of the bracketing.
Let me run it again.
So because it's running
all of the code,
it's just going to
train the network again.
OK.
There's epoch 2, epoch 3.
Hello.
There we go.
So let's remember
earlier I said I'm just
training it for five epochs.
It just makes it a
little bit quicker.
And I'm also seeing-- if
you look at the convergence,
on epoch 1 it was 82% accurate.
Oh, we got it wrong for 42.
It predicted it would be a
6, but it's actually a 3.
But the first epoch you
see, this accuracy figure--
82.45%.
That means it calculated
it was 82% accurate.
The second epoch, 86%
accurate; the third, 87%;
all the way down to the fifth--
89%.
I could probably train
it for 500 epochs,
but we don't have the time.
But then it might be more
likely to get number 42 correct.
And thanks, Mr. Douglas
Adams, that you've actually
given me one that doesn't work,
so I can go back and test it.
OK.
So that's Fashion
MNIST and how it works.
And so hopefully, this was
a good introduction to you
for really the concept from
a programmer's perspective
of what machine
learning is all about.
And I always like
to say at talks
that if you only take one
slide away from this talk,
if you've never done
machine learning,
or you want to get into
programming machine learning,
take this one here.
Because this is really what
the core of the revolution
is all about, and
hopefully the code that I
showed you demonstrates that--
that machine learning
is really all
about taking answers and
data and feeding them in
to get rules out.
I didn't write a single line
of code there today that says,
this is a t-shirt, or this is
a jacket, or this is a handbag.
This has sleeves.
If has sleeves, then is t-shirt.
If has heels, then is shoe.
I didn't have to write
any of that kind of code.
I just trained
something on the data
using the below thing, the
below part of the diagram--
feeding in answers,
feeding in data,
building a model that will
then infer the rules about it.
So with that, I just want
to say thank you very much,
and I hope you enjoy the
rest of the conference.
[APPLAUSE]